gehe erst mal zum friseur was wir in
deutschland eigentlich los wenn wir das
sagen würden zu dieser frau zu ronja mal
zahlen dieser jungen deutschen sängerin
songschreiberin die sogenannte
dreadlocks trägt geht erst mal zum
friseur
das sagt tatsächlich jetzt ausgerechnet
freundes for future die klimaschützer
die wollen ronja eigentlich bei ihrer
großen klima demo haben aber nicht so
nicht mit diesen hahn und das nicht weil
sie es nicht schön finden würden sondern
mit dieser irren begründung weiße
menschen die sollten bitteschön keine
dreadlocks tragen ronja würde sich mit
ihren dreadlocks nämlich die kultur
schwarzer menschen aneignen ohne dabei
die rassistische unterdrückung zu
erleben und das geht nicht sagen die
klimaaktivisten
verrückt gibt's nicht bild reporter
michael engelberg der hat ronja heute
getroffen hören sie mal was sie dazu
sagt und ob sie die frisur jetzt ändert
ja dieser post hat tatsächlich für große
wellen gesorgt und wir stehen jetzt hier
in ascheberg im münsterland und ich
stehe hier mit ronja malzahn ronja wir
haben uns auf ein duo geeinigt es ja
schon alles so ein bisschen unglaublich
erklär uns was genau passiert ist also
eigentlich wollten wir freitag bei der
demonstration fall des für future in
hannover teil sein mit unserer musik ein
zeichen zu setzen für frieden und
offenheit und für umweltschutz und
letzte nacht habe ich die nachricht auf
instagram gelesen dass wir nichts
eingeladen sind aufgrund von meinem
äußeren erscheinungsbild aufgrund von
meiner haare
und da war ich sehr überrascht und
schockiert davon dass die ja eigentlich
mit unserer musik für vielfalt und
kulturelle toleranz einstehen wollen und
da jetzt nicht eingeladen werden ich
hatte auch schon ein telefonat mit
freude ist für future da haben sie sich
glücklicherweise für den tonfall
entschuldigt
der in dieser nachricht mit klagen dass
ich mir ja bis freitag überlegen konnte
aber ich meine haare abschneiden möchte
um dann im programm mit aufgenommen zu
werden ich glaube dass diese
formulierung einfach sehr unsensibel
gewählt war und ich suche jetzt den
dialog mit haider ist future und hoffe
dass das
zu einem guten dialog amt was hat frames
for future gegen die dreadlocks
also ich glaube bei dem thema kalte
progression das ist ja ein ganz großes
thema das ist glaube ich eines wo man
wirklich differenziert hingucken muss in
welchem falle
kulturen verletzt diskriminiert oder
persönlich angegriffen werden indem man
sich kulturelles gut aneignet am in der
musik in äußeren erscheinungsbildern und
ich finde dass es ganz wichtig ist da
genau hinzugucken und in unserem fall
hat es mich einfach so verblüfft und so
überrascht irritiert weil wir eigentlich
mit unserer musik gesungen auf sieben
verschiedenen sprachen und wir reisen
sehr sehr viel wir haben ein buntes team
aus 15 musikern aus verschiedenen
ländern und am kooperieren sehr viel mit
internationalen künstlern allein unser
letztes musikvideo haben wir mit einer
ukrainischen
künstlerinnen für den frieden
veröffentlicht und das daraus jetzt so
eine ein konflikt entsteht finde ich
ganz ganz schade
du sagst dass ihr steht dafür ein nicht
diskriminieren zu seine seit weltoffen
ihr wollt das unterstützen bist du jetzt
ein bisschen enttäuscht ich meine das
ist ja schon auch eine ansage also du
darfst wenn du dir die haare abschneidet
ist also das könnte man jetzt auch zu
mir sagen du kannst kommen wenn ihr die
brille abnehmen ist aber was löst das in
die aus also ich persönlich
versuche das zu trennen das nicht als
persönlichen angriff auf meine person zu
sehen es tut mir viel mehr eigentlich
leid für die organisation frei das für
future die ich für eine sehr sinnvolle
organisation halte die eigentlich für
total gute werte in unserer gesellschaft
bei jungen leuten ein steht dass durch
diese ungünstige formulierung und durch
diese nachricht von einem individuum
jetzt eine ganze gruppe ja so
[Musik]
wenn ein konflikt kommt in den medien
jetzt habt ihr euch aber natürlich auch
bewusst dafür entschieden damit auch an
die öffentlichkeit zu gehen das hätte
man ja vielleicht auch anders machen
können aber nicht um jetzt krawall zu
machen sondern um wieder einzufangen um
wieder zu binden wir sind jetzt die
nächsten schritte also im nächste woche
versuche ich auf jeden fall noch mal ein
strukturiertes gespräch mit feiner
future zu suchen am und grundsätzlich
möchte ich gerne mit unserer musik dafür
einstehen dass
die kulturen
die vielfalt zelebriert werden sollte
und deswegen möchte ich mich darauf
künstlerisch und kreativ fokussieren
also wir haben jetzt im sommer ein
großes konzert geplant für udo
lindenberg wo wir eine neue cd
veröffentlichen und da freue ich mich
riesig drauf darauf richten wir unsere
kräfte und an unsere energien und hoffen
dass dieser konflikt nicht groß ausartet
gehört in berlin wir gehen davon aus und
runter geht auch davon aus dass frei fit
for future eventuell nicht mit dieser
großen welle gerechnet hat die dieser
posten geschlagen hat man ist im dialog
man versucht dass wieder alles zu
glätten und da kann man ja nur hoffen
dass sich beide seiten wieder annähern
und dass so was im internet nicht noch
mal passiert